mimi and indiana have been diagnosed
with long
covid their parents are convinced that
their three
brothers have it too i was having chest
pains
that we thought might have something to
do with my heart when i'm exercising
i always get short breath and i'm
struggling to breathe
i felt like my heart was going to stop
the whole family fell ill at the start
of the pandemic
since then they've had persistent rashes
ulcers nosebleeds and extreme lethargy
it's it's been really tough because
obviously myself and my husband weren't
well either
so dealing with being unwell ourselves
and then
dealing with five children who were sick
and two who were
seemingly much worse and not really
getting any support or answers
was yeah really worrying stressful
and mentally tough as was as well as
going through
the physical illness as well according
to research by campaigners
there are more than 80 000 children in
england
living with long covered headaches are a
common symptom
as is chest pain and one of the worst
for many youngsters
is stomach problems we've got over 2 000
children that are not getting better we
don't have
one recovery story and what we really
need is for researchers and doctors to
be much more curious about the effects
of long-covered on children
so that we can then make wise decisions
going forward ten-year-old isabelle was
once
full of energy now she has to be carried
to bed at night
and only managed half an hour at school
last week
if i get too tired out i would just not
do anything for about five days now
nearly five months on and have
just this week um been accepted
it's long covered and she's been
referred to a chronic fatigue
team um these the long covered clinics
that you hear
on the news the government
singing about that they've got all these
long cover clinics
they're just for adults they're not
taking children
this family and many others don't know
what the end game will be
they're fighting to have their health
problems recognized
and have no idea how long they'll last
lisa dowd sky news milton keynes